blinkist is the app that helps you
become a more well-rounded person by
letting you read or listen to an
entire non-fiction book in just 15
minutes you can try it for free
and get 25 off a subscription by going
to blinkist.com
pakman welcome everybody um i want to
start today with something that's really
interesting but not
super surprising which is that the
united states coronavirus vaccination
map
looks just like the 2020 presidential
election results map if you want to
predict which states voted for trump
look at the states
that aren't really getting vaccinated at
the higher rates in the country
if you want to predict which states are
getting vaccinated
look at the list of states where joe
biden got more
of a share of the vote relative to
donald trump and it's actually
incredible how accurately this can
predict
vaccination if you look at the top 25
states
in terms of what portion of the
population has been vaccinated
joe biden won 21 of those 25 states in
the 2020 election
when you look at the bottom 25 states
in terms of vaccination rate donald
trump won
21 of those 25 states including
16 of the worst 17 states
when it comes to vaccination the
correlation
between vaccination rate and the 2020
election outcome
by state has strengthened over time and
that's another important thing to
consider we've talked about how
anti-vaccine sentiment has declined over
time even among republicans like for
example
last month 43 of republicans didn't want
the vaccine
this month only 41 percent of
republicans don't want the vaccine
even within that if you are a republican
in a blue state
you are far more likely to want a
vaccine than if you are a republican in
a red state now in addition to this
there's a big urban rural
divide when it comes to vaccination just
like there's an urban rural divide in
trump versus biden
but let's put some visuals to this for
people who are
watching us today check out some of
these images from aca
signups.net this is a chart of
vaccination rate
versus trump support at the state level
and you see that the numbers are
arranged along a diagonal line
to the right it is a higher trump vote
and you see a
lower vaccination rate it's just a
perfect plot
to the left is a higher biden vote and
you see much
higher vaccination rates now you could
say hold on a second david hold on sir
um states vary in population
you have really big blue states and you
have some really small red states so if
you just look at states that could be
deceptive it might not really give us an
accurate picture of this the second
image here
from aca signups.net is county by county
and similarly although you have more
outliers like there are some blue
counties where very few people want to
get vaccinated i would love to know
where those are
but it's basically the same patter
pattern higher trump vote
lower vaccination higher biden vote
higher vaccination and it only requires
thinking back to the last what 15
16 months to understand what's going on
here if you have been told for a year
by your fearless leader this isn't
serious
this is like the flu 15 cases will soon
be zero
we don't need masks we don't need to
close we need kids in schools
you might get the sense that you don't
really need a vaccine and thus you
aren't going to go and get yourself one
trump said it would be gone in april
last april
of ape not one month ago 13 months ago
why would you need a vaccine
for that but the real tragedy here
is that politicizing the tax rate
okay you know politicizing debt and
deficit that's one thing
if something that is simply a public
health
measure that saves lives like a
vaccination
that is 90 plus percent effective if
that
can fall into the same political traps
the same political games
then quite literally anything can and
that's a horrifying reality to have to
accept
there are trumpists now posting to
social media
like a badge of honor that they have not
and they will not get vaccinated and the
government's not going to tread on them
and force them to get vaccinated well
yeah no the government's not going to
force you to do it of course we know
that
but they are wearing this lack of
vaccination as a badge of honor now so
at the end of the day
trump's politicization of the pandemic
continues trump's gone but it will
continue to cause deaths
american deaths due to this anti-vaccine
sentiment and increasingly because of
this partisan split
trump's mishandling and propagandizing
around the pandemic
will lead to more republican deaths than
democratic deaths
as we have increasingly i mean there are
blue states that are at 70
vaccinated already that's essentially
hurt immunity cases are going
to zero almost statistically um
not literally zero statistical zero
where you get down to a number that
you know the r the the rate of
reproduction is extremely low
um this is an incredible situation
because it is going to take on an
incredible partisan divide as we go
forward with
red state and republican clusters of the
virus
uh it's a horrible thing and i don't
care what your partisan uh
identification is i don't want anybody
to die i don't want anybody to get sick
and we are very quickly seeing an
incredible red blue divide happening
when it comes to
vaccination okay so i tweeted about this
yesterday and got some really
interesting
responses so i decided to talk about it
today i've been self-censoring
uh on the program or censoring myself as
some would say
over the issue of recent anti-semitic
attacks
all over the world all over the country
and all over the world
my instinct is never to do this if
there's a story that i want to cover i
cover the story
but i will be very honest with you the
degree of anti-semitism that we've
received across all platforms over the
last two weeks
just for my coverage of the
israeli-palestinian conflict without
actually talking about anti-semitism
really
has been insane we have had to ban
hundreds and hundreds of people
across our platforms from everything
from calling me
a jew rat to people saying blow up all
jews
blow up israel which i consider to be
just as unproductive
as those people who claim that the
pro-israeli side wants to blow up all
palestinians like it's
it it's just as disgusting and
i did something that i don't feel great
about
which is i didn't do a story that i
wanted to do since last week
i wanted to do a story about how
criticism of the israeli government and
foreign policy
which is valid and in which i
participate myself and have for a long
time
that has become cover for fuel for
an opening for just out and out
anti-semitism and even physical violence
against random jewish people or people
believed to be jewish out on the streets
normally i'd be telling you but i
haven't about all of these different
things and yesterday i tweeted
if i'm completely honest i hesitate to
do a segment covering the anti-semitic
attacks and beatings of the last week
because i don't have the stomach for the
deluge of anti-semitism
that such a segment would trigger
against me
even the responses to that tweet
were filled with anti-semitic comments
which immediately led to me just
blocking a whole bunch of people and i'm
not going to highlight any of those
messages today
but i've decided to talk about this
today partially because of some of the
positive responses i received
and also because it's already not being
talked about enough
as i see coverage of
this issue the the anti-semitic attacks
are already not getting enough coverage
and if i don't talk about it i'm helping
for it to be erased and i can't do that
now for some reason there are some on
the left
who do not talk about anti-semitism
either because they believe it conflicts
with their views about israeli foreign
policy which is a
different topic israeli foreign policy
and anti-semitism
are two different topics unless you only
talk about the former
to hide the latter but that's a very
specific case
uh some on the left don't talk about
anti-semitism because they see
jewish americans as an elite privileged
group
which in and of itself is actually based
on an anti-semitic trope
so i know that this is going to be a
mess i know we'll have to block another
few hundred people
but we have to talk about what's been
going on for example three men went to a
synagogue in new york city
made anti-semitic comments to just four
dudes hanging out outside and vandalized
the synagogue
a synagogue in chicago has been
vandalized
thursday night a random jewish man in
new york city's times square was beaten
up just in the middle of the street a
beating
29 year old with a yarmulke in new york
city assaulted by a violent mob
called a filthy jew a dirty jew saying
hamas will
kill all of you and israel will burn
guys that's not a criticism of israeli
foreign policy that's
anti-semitism in los angeles a group of
people went to a sushi restaurant
and shouted anti-israeli comments at
people they believed to be jews
while brandishing a deadly weapon in bal
halber
bal harbour florida eric organ said he
was walking with his family
with uh with his fa while vacationing
when four men in an suv began yelling
anti-semitic comments oregon was wearing
a yarmulke
the men shouted free palestine and die
jew as well as threats to rape his wife
and daughter
they threw garbage at the family feces
has been left outside of a synagogue
another man torched a jewish community
center
synagogues in some places are now hiring
armed security
i could go on but it's not necessary
because the big picture
is that officials say hate crimes
against jews are growing dramatically
in the aftermath of the recent
israeli-palestinian flare-up
and violence we are witnessing a
dangerous and drastic surge in
anti-jewish hate
said the head of the anti-defamation
league the anti-defamation league has
identified 193 reports of anti-jewish
incidents in the last week
135 reports the week before
and the point here is and i really wish
that some of the anti-israeli people
understood this
when israel does something and jews
around the world
many of whom have never been to israel
most of whom have never been to israel
are attacked on the streets it makes
more and more people say
wow i might have to move to israel
someday
i hope people understand this if you
really want to help make progress on the
israeli-palestinian conflict and get
more people on your side
like me fighting for a safe and fair
situation for israelis and palestinians
lifting the blockade stopping the
settlements getting leaders on both
sides that actually care about
the people in a real way right don't do
stuff that makes jewish people say holy
it's insane out there i might need to
move to israel to feel safe
this is the great conundrum the more of
this stuff that goes on
the more people will say i don't care
what israel does
because i might need to flee there
someday and we saw this in europe as
anti-semitism exploded under trump
due to not because of trump but during
the trump era we saw the far-right
nationalist movements in europe
and anti-semitism the desire to move to
israel
for safety went up so the best thing
that these people can do
if they can put their anti-semitism on
hold for a second
is don't make random jews around the
world feel unsafe
don't make jews on the streets of new
york city
feel so unsafe that they say i might
have to move to israel
to be safe okay so it's an incredible
conundrum
and so counterproductive and obviously
toxic and disgusting so
listen i know what a lot of the reaction
will be to me doing this segment
uh but i can't not say anything about it
um let me know your thoughts you can
find me on twitter
at d pacman what if you could read
10 books in just one sitting that's
exactly
what one of my favorite apps lets you do
it's called blinkist and what they do is
take
thousands of popular nonfiction books
they condense them down
into text or audio that you can consume
in 15 minutes
blinkist makes sure that you're getting
all of the
important core insights from each book
so it's perfect for exploring a book you
otherwise wouldn't have time for
if there's a full book you're thinking
about buying you can use blinkist to get
a sample
first just think how much you can enrich
yourself
by being able to soak up an entire
nonfiction book
in just 15 minutes i recently read a
brief history of time of course by the
great
stephen hawking this is a book that i
have been aware of for so long and
other things got in the way and it was
fantastic
to check it out on blinkist blinkist has
books on politics philosophy science
they have 27 different non-fiction
categories and a subscription
is only about 8 bucks a month and you
get the entire
library but you can try it totally free
and get 25 off a subscription when you
go to blinkist.com
david pakman i've put the link right
underneath this video
monday memorial day we're doing a
one-day membership special i would love
for you to sign up today at
joinpacman.com
but if you want to wait for just an
insanely crazy coupon code
to get a big discount off of membership
monday memorial day is the day we'll be
sending out our newsletter on monday
morning
with a uh incredibly i mean i would call
it an immoral coupon code it's that
cheap
um get on my newsletter at
davidpakman.com and you'll be notified
monday morning
listen they simply will not stop another
ballot audit
is set to go forward in fulton county
georgia
and yes this is for the 2020
presidential election now
let's sit back for a second and review
yes obviously joe biden won georgia
yes obviously even if biden lost georgia
he would still have the necessary 270
electoral votes to be president of the
united states
yes obviously the georgia results have
been certified
and confirmed and recounted and audited
for joe biden
multiple times and nothing can change
now and yes
obviously joe biden has been president
for months and this isn't
an absurd and humiliating fiasco for
republicans
but they will not stop cnn reports that
another ballot audit
or ardet as some say is set to move
ahead
in georgia's most populous county after
a judge ruled friday
that absentee ballots could be unsealed
for parties looking to examine them
for evidence of fraud georgia
republicans plan to bring in
six so-called experts by the way
sometimes you see these experts and you
say dear god
um they're gonna bring in six experts to
look at the ballots
and see if they can determine whether
there are characteristics
pointing to counterfeit ballots now
remember
georgia counties already did the initial
count
a hand audit a rescan of each ballot
and every single one of those actions
confirmed that
joe biden won georgia you know who loves
this decision though
about doing another audit former
republican senator
kelly leffler from georgia who was
handily defeated by now democratic
senator rafael warnock she refers to him
as
radical liberal raphael warnock
she applauded this new audit saying
quote voter confidence in our election
system is the bedrock of our republic
unfortunately inconsistencies in fulton
county's november 2020 absentee ballots
cast serious doubt on voters faith in
our elections now one
upside here just for hilarity is that
they won't even be given the real
ballots to review i love this
they will be given scanned images of the
ballots
i don't know why i love that but they're
not even going to let them put their
hands on the actual ballots now
this wouldn't be so much an audit but an
attempt to tamper
really so it's probably smart not to
give them actual ballots but just the
signed images
and i read one commentary about this
that says
you know allowing this to go forward is
a mistake because it's yet another seed
of doubt that gets planted in the minds
of those who want to believe this was
stolen
something that might convince someone
that there was
fraud i think that that ship has long
sailed if you think there was fraud
you think there was fraud and none of
this stuff matters you just think there
was fraud
most people have moved on and another
pseudo-audit or forensic examination of
remember when they wanted to look at
bamboo fibers in arizona or whatever
i don't think it'll really make a
difference at this point in public
opinion
now um what is the latest that a judge
could even allow them to do something
like could you continue
auditing and reviewing ballots from 2020
beyond the 2022 mid midterms i have no
idea i don't know how long
it's possible for this to go on and of
course the troubling part
of all of this is you really can't prove
a negative and this is we've done a lot
of stories about
how conspiracy theories work and
conspiracism and conspiratorial thinking
when they find nothing for the second
time and the third time and the fourth
time and the fifth time
they instead of saying there's probably
nothing to find
they say you know they've done a really
good job of hiding it if we did a
sixth audit we would then find the
smoking gun that we're waiting for
the fact that we've not found anything
in four reviews
is only evidence that they've hidden the
fraud really really well
and as i've said before healthy
skepticism is good
and thinking for ourselves is good and
understanding
what is the foundation of a belief how
did i come to believe a certain thing
that's all good never ending skepticism
if you never want to be satisfied you
can find a way to never be satisfied and
that's exactly what they are doing here
and a real hallmark of conspiracy
theorists
is that evidence for something counts as
evidence
and lack of evidence for that thing also
counts as evidence
because hiding the evidence is part of
the plan
and when you if you don't reason your
way
into a belief you're not going to get
reasoned out of it and i've said that
many
times before and that's clearly a case
of what's going on here but
they're continuing to keep going that's
in georgia
and we also have some more interesting
news now out of arizona
um you guys know that phrase when it
rains it pours
it just won't stop pouring for donald
trump's former lawyer
rudy giuliani there's a new report that
rudy giuliani reportedly called
an arizona official about getting the
election
challenge quote fixed up so that
donald trump would win arizona back
during the 2020 election now remember
that
flipping arizona alone would not have
given donald trump the presidency
anyway remember that rudy giuliani is
already under a major investigation his
home and his office were raided just a
few weeks ago
and now this the arizona republic
revealed on sunday
that rudy giuliani called the maricopa
county supervisor bill gates
not the microsoft guy just a guy with
the same name on christmas eve of 2020
to introduce himself as the lawyer for
donald trump he left an incredible
message it's almost mafia-like
about getting this situation resolved
for everybody
check out this quote the arizona
newspaper obtained the audio and
published a transcript
rudy left a message saying quote bill
it's rudy giuliani president trump's
lawyer
if you get a chance would you please
give me a call i have a few things
a few things i'd like to talk over with
you maybe we can get this thing
fixed up you know i really think it's a
shame
that republicans sort of are both in
this kind of
situation and i think there may be a
nice way
to resolve this for everybody
why does every rudy giuliani quote
throughout this entire thing
sound like something you'd expect to
hear on the sopranos
not from the lawyer to a sitting
president of the united states
the difference is i would imagine that a
real mobster
wouldn't leave a message like this on a
phone with their real name and speaking
so
uh explicitly about what it is that they
want it would be
you know someone shows up at the house
of this
maricopa county supervisor and says hey
our friend in dc says
he wants to talk about the arizona thing
and get it fixed up
you understand but no rudy just does it
he does it without any hesitation he
just does it via voicemail
and gates has since been asked about the
voicemail and said
i never returned rudy's call explaining
that quote
we don't do what is easy we do what is
right
what's scary about that is the
implication that it would have been easy
to just flip the results and give the
state to trump
i hope that's not what supervisor gates
actually means here now many of you have
been emailing me regularly saying how is
rudy not in jail
already there are many answers to that
question the
first is people like rudy don't tend to
go to jail
we have a two-tier justice system and
people like rudy
tend not to end up in jail or in prison
second
is that the investigation that's
currently ongoing was significantly
obstructed by trump appointees to the
justice department when trump was
president they are now coming out and
saying
biden got rudy's home in office raided
no actually the investigation started
when trump was still president and they
tried to get a search warrant all the
way back then
but trump appointees in the justice
department obstructed it and blocked it
and prevented it from happening so
this all would have happened under trump
had trump's loyalists in the justice
department not interfered
and third i just don't think rudy
giuliani is going to prison period and
whenever i say that people are angry or
people say david you should at least
optimistically say let's hope rudy goes
to prison okay
if rudy committed crimes for which he is
found guilty
i hope he's given prison time that would
be a that would be just
uh after everything that he's been
involved in i don't believe rudy's going
to prison
i don't believe trump is going to prison
and so i'm not going to
gaslight you and tell you that i think
that that's a realistic possibility
that's
that's just what it is uh if you
disagree if you think that
there's some real way that rudy giuliani
ends up in prison and to be perfectly
frank
even if rudy's charged and doesn't plead
out and is found guilty
at rudy's age and for this type of crime
i think that once you get to sentencing
he doesn't get sent to prison
anyway even with multiple guilty
verdicts i just don't see it
okay if you disagree let me know and
we're going to have
more coverage of this on the david
pakman show instagram which you can find
at david pakman show
if you want to see a really wacky and i
mean
weaponized hate mail that i received
last night
find it on my personal instagram
david.pacman alright quick break right
back after this
the david pakman show depends on your
support and the easiest way
is through membership which includes the
world famous bonus show as well as
commercial free audio
and video streams of the show just for
members
sign up today at joinpacman.com
coupon code saves you 40 better 21.
it's great to welcome back to the
program today dr isaac bogosh who is an
infectious diseases physician
and scientist based out of the
university of toronto and toronto
general hospital
uh it's so great to have you back on
today thanks for having me back on great
to see you again david
so we could start in many different
places i mean let's just start with an
overview
we're starting to see vaccination
accelerate
in a lot of different places we're
seeing it in canada
the united states europe seems to be
about five and a half six weeks behind
where the united states is
and other places as well cases are
starting to decline
globally and then certainly much more
precipitously
in some particular countries the big
question everybody has is is is this the
end
and if so the end of what right and is
this going to go from being
pandemic to seasonal what's like the big
picture assessment right now
i think the big picture assessment is as
you point out some places are much
farther along than others
united kingdom israel united states are
clearly
far ahead you see cases plummeting you
see life slowly and in some places not
so slowly returning
back to normal um the rest of the world
is either a few months behind or sadly
sadly a year to a year and a half to
even two years behind
um it's gonna take a while i really hope
the countries that are further along
start to look more globally
start to think more about low-income
countries and low-middle-income
countries around the world that just
don't have the same access to vaccines
i hope we start to pour tons of time
tons of energy tons of resources
tons of vaccine vaccines into the kovacs
program to really help
from a global equity standpoint help
vaccinate those less fortunate than us
but uh you know in general in general i
do see the pendulum slowly from a global
standpoint
shifting toward things getting better
you know cases are starting to drop in
some of the more hybrid areas like
brazil and india they're still a long
way away from where they need to be
but at least they might be heading in
the right direction and you know quite
frankly
vaccines are here like we're in the
vaccine era we now have
tools to prevent this to prevent people
from getting sick to brand people from
dying we just have to get
we have to mass produce those and get
those all over the world which is you
know easy to say but actually hard to do
one of the common questions maybe the
biggest question right now around
vaccines is
what about the variants and we've had
the british variant south african
brazilian new york california
india from what i've been reading the
current
major variants are all the way i am
reading it is
well enough handled by the current
vaccines doesn't mean there's
no escape versus the sort of original
you know live version for which the
vaccines were made but that if we
vaccinate quickly enough
these vaccines are good enough is that
your understanding
yeah i see it the same way too basically
if we think about the first generation
vaccines that we have
again in the united states canada and
europe um
they're they're either really really
good
or good enough and that's fine because
quite frankly if you can turn a
potentially lethal infection
into the sniffles you're doing something
right right you don't have
the same public health emergency that
you would have when
you know a virus runs the virus runs
unchecked and obviously preys upon
everybody but
really significantly on those on the
older end of the spectrum are people
with underlying medical conditions so
i think the vaccines that we have are
absolutely fantastic
obviously the the elephant in the room
is listen when you've got
unchecked transmission in some parts of
the world
there's always the concern that you may
develop
a virus that escapes the vaccine you
know and
and we don't have that yet right uh i
have no idea if that will happen
but that's that's the concern uh but we
don't have that
and quite frankly i think as you point
out the key message here is
vaccinate vaccinate vaccinate we just
have to roll these out to as many people
all over the planet as fast as possible
to get some degree of community level
protection and
again you don't have to have that
mythical herd immunity level you just
have to have
good rates in the community to really
slow this down you'll protect
individuals you protect populations and
that's the right path forward
i think the other point on this is we're
going to get a booster we all know it
they're already starting to make it the
boosters really start to account for
some of the variants of concern
probably something we're going to be
talking about either in very late 2021
or
early 2022 right but beyond that it's
not entirely clear what the frequency of
vaccines is going to be
but i think it's fair to say that we get
we're going to get two doses now or one
with the johnson and johnson
and one at least one dose later on
hopefully that's it but there may be
more
so last time you were on we talked a
little bit about
masks and outdoor versus indoor and
i i if i recall correctly you and i seem
to be in agreement
not that my opinion matters as much as
yours but but from what i read it seemed
to
go along with the things you believe
about outside transmission
is very very low but we are team players
and so
when the guidelines were you wear a mask
everywhere
i was doing it even on the bike path and
so on and so forth even if i didn't
really think that that was
where where a lot of the spread was
we've since found
out um dr ashish jha from brown
published something saying that
pre-vaccine maybe one out of a thousand
cases was being transmitted outdoors and
that was
probably pretty obvious situations where
you're outdoors but doing something you
you probably shouldn't be doing
in the u.s the cdc has since said if
you're vaccinated you don't really need
a mask outdoors then they've since gone
to if you're vaccinated really
you don't need a mask at all but follow
what your state says or follow what a
particular retailer says
things are different in canada for sure
some reactions have been
that new guidance is crazy kids aren't
vaccinated
yet the vaccines aren't 100 percent
etcetera etcetera what's your general
reaction to the speed with which the cdc
has moved in the u.s
ah listen i'm i'm a big fan of the
the new cdc under dr rafael wilinski
um yeah i get that this is always going
to be a contentious issue
people are going to have very strong
opinions one way or another
but i tend to align with them right i
mean what
what this is the point of vaccines right
this is what they do
and now they're doing it they were
supposed to a prevent you from getting
the infection
and b if you're unlucky enough to get
the infection
ensure that you have a very mild illness
and c
reduce the likelihood if you're unlucky
enough to get the infection that you
transmit the infection
to others we do not live in a zero
risk world especially in the covet era
now you have these phenomenal vaccines
that are
extremely effective but of course
they're not a hundred percent perfect
i totally think that when you have a
significant degree
of vaccination in your community in this
case in the united states you know no of
course you don't have a hundred percent
uptake nor will you ever get to that
state but you have a ton of people that
have a first dose you have a ton of
people that have a second dose you
already have
excellent labs or not lab data trial
data
and real world experience with these
vaccines
great i don't i mean i think it's very
reasonable if you're fully vaccinated
like
why do you need to wear a mask and then
what about the issue of
of kids right where if you're under
nobody under 12 has been vaccinated
they just started pfizer 12 plus
that's something i hear from parents who
say well i will keep wearing a mask
because the kids aren't vaccinated even
if i am does that make sense
scientifically
not really like let's think about it
it's this is goes beyond science and
more into value judgments
right if let's just think about this
critically if a parent is fully
vaccinated
okay you've got your two doses of i
don't know maduro pfizer or something
like that
can you get the infection yes but it's
unlikely
if you're infected will you get really
sick no
but it's not impossible if you are
infected can you transmit it to your kid
it's always possible it's just very very
unlikely so these are people's value
judgments that's
totally totally fine if people's risk
threshold or risk perception
uh is or risk tolerance is as such where
they feel that they still want to wear a
mask great i would never
shame or blame anyone from wearing a
mask i think the whole point here is to
enable people to make informed decisions
for themselves
i think it's also fair to enable people
to say listen if you're fully vaccinated
here's the risks if you choose to not
wear a mask that's also okay too
we're in a bit of a wild west right now
right rapidly emerging data
rapidly uh uh you know vaccinating large
large segments of the population policy
has got to keep up with science and
and that means it's going to change
quickly with time
here's one that caught some people off
guard it's still a reasonable policy
but again there's no shaming there's no
blaming if you want to wear a mask
great if you want to take your mask off
great as long as you're making an
informed decision you're doing something
right the last
piece of this was in the us there's a
significant
anti-vaccine community which overlaps
with
donald trump voters at least for the
time being
and the concern was you know now that
the cdc said
vaccinated people don't need to wear
masks unvaccinated people will just lie
and not wear masks and the debate was
are they only putting themselves at risk
or are they putting
others at risk and it's really a
statistical question right
yeah i mean i think it's fair to say
they're putting themselves at risk
and of course they're putting others at
risk as well this is one of those
situations i i mean this with love and
respect like i really don't mean any ill
will toward anyone but
if we look at the look at the united
states and the situation there
vaccines are so widely available
it's to the point where some are even
being discarded right
if you're any walk of life it's
available like it's in pharmacies it's
in doctor's offices if you go to the
emergency department
for an unrelated issue you'll get one on
the way out it's in the subway stations
like it's
they're everywhere okay we often talk
about equity in vaccine
allocation and distribution but like
it's true like the barriers to getting a
vaccine
are really really low for almost all
walks of life it's not perfect but
it it's pretty clear that almost anyone
can get a vaccine so that's point one
point two is some people are going to
choose to get a vaccine some people are
gonna choose not to get a vaccine great
your choice your body muscle top but the
third point is
this is such a contagious infection
that people who choose not to get
vaccinated
your luck's going to run out eventually
right your luck is going to run out
there's just so much of this virus
everywhere
globally even in the united states like
people will
sadly get infected eventually if they
choose not to get vaccinated and again
i don't want i don't wish ill on anyone
but it's going to reach a point where
you've said listen we've given everybody
ample opportunity to get a vaccine you
can change your mind you can get a
vaccine anywhere you want
you've chosen not to that's your choice
that's your decision but like
we know what happens like you don't you
don't need a crystal ball to look in the
future and see
that many of those individuals sadly who
are either on the either on the older
end of the spectrum or have medical
conditions
are going to get sick and land in
hospital some of them are going to die
and
you know that's awful that's awful
because it's completely preventable
yeah one of the i mean i've been
stressing to my audience
there are countries that have no
vaccines right now there are countries
that they get a shipment of a hundred
thousand
and they're thrilled with a hundred
thousand vaccines
we have so many vaccines in the united
states and increasingly in other
countries as well canada europe getting
more and more vaccines
and you know 40 of trump voters just
don't want to get one
it's almost insulting it's disgusting i
don't know what the right word
to attach to it is i mean it's
it's it's perplexing it's mind-boggling
it's sad
and and you know sometimes you just stop
start blaming yourself like oh as a
medical or as a scientific or as a
public health community
we haven't done enough i mean obviously
it's more complicated than this right
this is
truly going to be a struggle moving
forward i mean this first of all this
predated coven 19 and this will be
this issue will be along well after
covet 19
is is an afterthought but we really
have to fight a better fight on
social media and in mainstream media and
in regular conversations
to enable people to make appropriate
decisions for themselves based on
data fact logic science
right like i listen i truly am all for
people making individual decisions for
themselves i would never want to
coerce people i would never want to
counterbalance
extreme misinformation against vaccines
with extreme misinformation
on the other side of the spectrum just
be honest just present the data in a
meaningful
digestible manner and the key here is
communication
in an age language and culturally
appropriate manner that's easily
digestible
but again i mean look what we're up
against we're up against
you know social media which does i know
they say they're trying to
combat this misinformation but like it's
a huge failure
uh we're up against you know people who
dig in their heels
and and cultural norms like this is
going to be a an uphill battle and sadly
sadly lives are going to be lost and
it's not
an insignificant number of lives like
this is going to be measured in the
thousands and thousands or quite frankly
in the ten thousands of lives
probably even more i mean there's half a
million americans died right yeah
half a million people died from this and
how many more are going to die
uh because of misinformation and
pseudoscience that's being amplified
online yeah and the real number it you
know officially 600 000
probably in reality 30 to 40 more it's
probably close to a million deaths
is the real number to follow up on a
couple of other things that when we last
spoke we were still learning about
the primary mode of transmission here in
terms of location we learned
outdoor is close to zero the bleaching
of the bananas and stuff like that that
was not
that was not prevent that was not a a
source of contagion
is it people indoors breathing on each
other is that really what this is
yes yes safe to say that the vast
majority of this infection is
transmitted
indoors with people in close contact
with each other can you still get this
infection
indoors while far away from other
someone else sure
sure you can there's you know tons of
case reports and examples of this but
primarily close contact indoors doesn't
have to be for you know that magic
number of 15 minutes
you can have a high exposure fleeting
contact uh you know it's gross to think
about better someone like cost in your
face
indoors you're gonna get this infection
even if it's for a second yeah yeah
indoor like it's safe to say you know to
oversimplify
indoor safe outdoor sorry
outdoor safe indoor not safe this is
it's basically as easy as that and and
you know policy can align with that you
know ventilate indoor spaces
put on a mask indoors pretty
straightforward stuff
and it seems that the x factor for
indoors from some studies i've read
really seems to be the type of
ventilation that you have these
situations where even with larger
distances between people
certain types of ventilation that that
are basically moving the virus around
can lead to people 20 feet away actually
getting it
but that that again we're now starting
to slice and dice
even smaller sort of situations i agree
completely i i mean
you can get this infection indoors it's
primarily indoors i mean distance
certainly helps it does you can't ignore
the fact that distance helps that masks
help
but most of this virus appears to be
transmitted
indoors in close contact with with one
another
um mass will help ventilation will help
but uh but you know at the end of the
day
like let's just get vaccinated that's
that's really our ticket out of this you
know we're not supposed to say there's a
silver bullet but there is
the vaccines are the silver bullet right
that is
protecting people protecting communities
it's
phenomenal to watch some of the real
world data emerge from places in the
united states from
israel from the united kingdom where you
just vaccinate a significant proportion
of your population you follow up with
the second dose
and you watch cases plummet like it's
just
remarkable it's remarkable and you know
when we're talking about respiratory
viral infection
i i'm fully aware that this is not the
flu but often we all we will say well
let's look at influenza vaccines and you
know influenza vaccines are
like they're comsicum i mean but but
like
they don't have effectiveness they're
not like 95
effective right now sometimes you know
20 30 40 50
effective depending on the year you've
got copic 19 vaccines that are like
90 percent effective for a contagious
respiratory virus like that's remarkable
like it's incredible you really are
transforming oh my god it's amazing and
the fact that
you know we're some people are saying
well this vaccine is you know
94 and this one was 92 like it's
ridiculous like they're
we're talking about vaccines that are
you know over 60
effective for a contagious respiratory
virus that's remarkable in and of itself
so
these are these are incredible vaccines
and they truly are transforming
the pandemic yeah even i was just
reading today about the possibility now
of an mrna-based flu vaccine which could
also be a game changer on those you know
20 to 20 to 50
numbers it's really incredible uh we've
been speaking with dr
isaac bogash who's an infectious disease
physician and scientist based out of the
university of toronto
and toronto general hospital always
great catching up with you thank you my
pleasure have a great day
the david pakman show depends on the
support of our viewers and listeners and
one way to keep us going is through
patreon
where you can pledge as little as one
dollar per month
or as much as you want at patreon.com
slash david pakman show great perks and
benefits as well
read about him all right this is truly
one of my favorite fail clips from the
last week on the fox news
show a fox and friends steve ducey who
has never struck
anybody as being particularly with it
let's be honest about about ducey
he tried citing the number of coveted
deaths and people affected nationally by
the virus
but what came out of his mouth didn't
make any sense and he sort of seems to
realize it
now you may know that in the united
states more than 33 million people have
officially gotten the virus
the real number is probably more like 65
million
and more than 600 000 people officially
have died
and yet in this segment steve ducey says
here in the u.s 52 000 people have died
and two million people have been
affected by covid and as he says it
you see a sort of strange look on his
face and at one point he looks off
screen to his right almost as if
someone's flagging him
as if he realizes that what he's saying
makes no sense
but he just can't seem to get back on
track so check it out
think about it this way folks here in
the united states of america
52 000 americans have died from
covet 52 000 i i was shocked to see that
33 000 of them actually lived here in
new york city which is shocking
uh 2 million americans have been
impacted so how did
it come to infect the entire
planet so this of course makes no sense
and what appears to have happened is
that ducey was trying to give the
coveted numbers
for new york state not for the united
states
which are close to the numbers he gave
and the state of new york
indeed 53 000 people have died of the
virus
about 2.1 million official cases
and later in the show ducey corrected
himself
he was apparently confused and he is
also a clown the correction hilariously
came during a segment about
what else of course cancel culture
now a ton of people wrote to me saying
david this isn't a mistake
this was as usual trying to throw in a
low number
and then correcting so that it doesn't
look as though
trump failed as bad no i don't think so
i think this was just a mistake
i think ducey didn't realize that the
numbers he was giving made no sense
until he said it and then he sort of
realized it i don't believe that this is
nefarious i think it's the constant
confusion happening at fox news
and the constant confusion going on in
the brain of steve ducey
the only strange thing about the clip is
that no one
immediately said in his ear piece new
york not us new york not you not u.s
and that he could have immediately
corrected and said sorry that that's in
new york state not in the united states
that is weird i admit that
i don't have an explanation for that but
this is actually an opportunity
to remind you the official numbers
uh are nowhere near the real estimated
number
of coveted cases and deaths and there's
a lot of different reasons for this
first we can talk about cases then we
can talk about deaths one study suggests
that cases which are officially 33
million
could be two to three times that number
so
33 million official cases the real u.s
number
could be 66 million or 99 million why
a bunch of different reasons early on
before we even
knew about this virus as a separate
virus
from the flu there were tons of people
who had symptoms there were no tests
available at that point in time
or not enough tests they tested for flu
came back negative and just were told go
home it's probably some virus that's a
whole bunch of people
in january 2020 february 2020 march even
into april i don't exactly remember was
it end of april early may when testing
really ramped up
so there's a whole bunch of people who
tested negative for the flu or never got
a test whatsoever
also a ton of asymptomatic cases now
the relevance of an asymptomatic case
you might say well we didn't capture in
the data
a lot of those asymptomatic cases but
they also don't really matter
okay that's a that's a debate but that's
another reason why the 33 million number
is very low people who had
an asymptomatic case or an almost
asymptomatic case
may never have thought to get tested so
real number of cases anywhere from two
to three times the official number
deaths one study suggests that the real
number of coveted deaths
could be not two to three times the
official number but could be 30 to 40
percent higher than the official
uh number one study says it could be 50
percent
higher how could that be um a bunch of
different reasons
one there is a degree to which
sometimes someone dies and it's just not
being reported
uh locally as a cove of death
number two there are people who died in
their homes
um where they were never posthumously
tested for covid and they are
sort of what we would call presumed
cases but not necessarily
uh known cases so also
a multiplier if you take the official
number of cova deaths if you want to get
to the real number
maybe you multiply by 1.3 1.4
maybe 1.5 so steve ducey yes constant
confusion going on there
whatever but an opportunity to remind
you that even when we look at the
official numbers and we say
here's how bad it was and we make a
judgment about that
the real numbers are probably 30 to
fifty percent more deaths
and two to three times more cases this
is
absolutely bizarre for a number of
reasons
donald trump's indicted former national
security adviser michael flynn
who has since been pardoned and is a
total out and out conspiracy theorist
appeared on some right wing show a few
days ago
and claimed that yes the election was
stolen
and yes covid was a conspiracy and all
of this stuff
but as crazy as all of that is he drops
in he's not worried
because he's been on hydroxychloroquine
for 30 years
what why has he been on
hydroxychloroquine for 30 years
and why would you need to be on
hydroxychloroquine if covet is a hoax
anyway none of it's make none of it
makes sense
why has he been taking the virus why why
has he been taking the medication
what did he know in 1991 at age 32
that would start him on a 30-year course
of hydroxychloroquine just some of the
questions
that come up let's take a listen to
michael flynn because when you look
around the world and you go well
all these other places why aren't all
these other places having the kinds of
problems that
that work we keep getting beat over the
head and shoulders on in this country
about when it comes to covet
why because everything everything and
this is
this is my my truth but what i believe
everything is a distraction to what
happened on the 3rd of november
so everything that we hear about kovid
and that coveted started before the 3rd
of november
but it was all meant to control it's all
meant to gain control of a society
to be able to to force decisions on the
society
instead of actually allowing we the
people to make decisions
imagine for a moment and this is the
this is the tragedy
that guy was the national security
adviser of the united states
for a period of time okay i've heard
from other people the idea kovid was
created
slash released to make trump lose the
election
this is one of the conspiracies that
doesn't even make sense
in terms of the motive sometimes you
have a bad conspiracy theory
and all they have is motive they have no
facts but at least the motive
sort of might work to convince you that
it's a possible conspiracy
kovid was created to make trump lose the
american election
doesn't even pass the sniff test because
there's no guarantee
that kovid would make a world leader up
for re-election lose if they handled the
virus correctly never mind that we've
had six hundred thousand official deaths
the world has had three and a half
million official deaths most of the
deaths are not in the u.s
so flynn is wrong that we are mostly
affected and everybody else is fine most
of the deaths have been in other
countries
second if you handle covet well you get
yourself reelected look at new zealand
where jacinda ardern
handled the virus beautifully easily got
reelected
and new zealand was able to reopen much
earlier than the united states so
to assume trump loses because of kovid
is sort of silly
unless you assume trump would mishandle
it which isn't as crazy
but it still goes against the idea of
what michael flynn is saying
but then he casually mentions i've been
on hydroxychloroquine for 30 years
and now with the with the vaccine as an
example right whatever happened to the
woman's movement
out there for the my body my choice but
yet
they want to stick a a needle in in my
arm
to tell me that well if you don't have
that needle you can't get an id card you
can't get it you can't travel
wait a second i'm as healthy as an
expert i've been i've been taking
hydrochloroquine for 30 years
okay so by by the way more lies there no
one has said you can't get a state id if
you don't get a vaccine
and in terms of travel there are
countries that are putting in place a
vaccine requirement for covet vaccine
for decades and decades different
countries have had different vaccine
requirements
that's nothing new okay but
hydroxychloroquine for 30 years
michael flynn is 62 years old right now
meaning 30 years ago he would have been
32 and it would have been 1991
why did he start taking
hydroxychloroquine in 1991 at 32 years
of age
has he had arthritis since age 32 one of
the reasons sometimes people take
hydroxychloroquine
has he been persistently exposed to
malaria for the last 30 years where he
needs to
constantly be on hydroxychloroquine has
he had lupus
since age 32 another reason why
sometimes you would take
hydroxychloroquine
if you take it for just five years
you need to get regular eye exams
because it can cause
retinopathy and michael flynn claims
that he's been on hydroxychloroquine for
30
years or is michael flynn implying that
as a prophylactic of some kind he's been
taking hydroxychloroquine for 30 years
which just makes no sense whatsoever
um and i i got one funny email which was
you know maybe 30 years of
hydroxychloroquine
have caused some kind of toxicity and
that explains all of michael flynn's
bizarre behavior the
paranoid delusions the conspiracy
theories all of it i don't know
and to come back again to the entire
covet hoax thing
if it's a hoax why do you need to take
anything
why take hydroxychloroquine for
something that's not real
if that's indeed what you believe and of
course by hoax they always mean
different things sometimes by hoax they
mean it's not really a virus and
nobody's dying from it
by hoax sometimes they mean no it's a
real virus and people are dying
but it was deliberately released to have
a political impact either on the united
states or the world or whatever the case
may be
it's never clear their conspiracy
theories conflict
but what is abundantly clear here is
that michael flynn is
completely off the rails and it is
terrifying
terrifying that that guy at one point
was the primary and most important
adviser on the topic of national
security
to the president of the united states we
have a voicemail number
that number is 2192 david p
you can call the voicemail number
anytime you want and
here's a really good question about all
of these so-called
voter integrity measures that
republicans have been and want to
continue passing take a listen to this
hey david these voter suppression
tactics
it's kind of hard to find the um
statistical analysis on their effect
could you could you share what percent
what percentage do they estimate
uh that these these tactics prevent
illegal voting or versions of that and
what percentage of voters who
want to vote yeah are unable to vote
because they've been purged from a voter
roll
or other suppression tactic where they
they said they were unable to vote i'm
just assuming that they estimate that
based on polls or something else
yeah so this this is a good question
which is all this stuff republicans do
legally speaking um in order to
prevent illegal voting how much illegal
voting does it actually prevent versus
how many
legal voters end up being
disenfranchised which is really the
design of it
there is absolutely no evidence
whatsoever that in-person voter fraud
is a materially significant issue now
it's important to say materially
significant because republicans will
hear that
and they'll write in and they'll say
what about jim bob who uh
voted twice or what about uh bobby sue
who figured out how to vote under her
cousin's name or whatever
the the question is you know in a
country of 331 million people there are
examples of everything
is there any evidence that all of these
in-person types of voter fraud are
materially significant to election
results and the answer is no
on the other hand we know of tons of
people who
were purged from voter rolls for
so-called inactivity
uh who were denied the ability to vote
because of other
uh clerical um issues that were caused
by
these guidelines and restrictions put in
place by republicans there are people
who opted just not to even go and vote
because republicans disproportionately
shut down voting
booths and curtail voting hours in
disproportionately democratic areas so
the the brennan center for justice has a
lot of great data on this and the most
important takeaway is
the voter suppression tactics from
republicans because that's what they are
which they
claim to be in the spirit of preventing
illegal votes
they do way more to interfere with
people legally voting
than they do to curb what is almost
insignific
almost non-existent and statistically
insignificant
in-person voter fraud the real way
that you affect elections is by
suppressing the vote
at the big picture level you don't flip
an election
by going with your friends to multiple
polling places
and claiming to be different people you
don't go and round up the people who are
juniors and say even
though your dad's senior is dead go and
vote for yourself and for your dad no
that's not how you steal an election
just doesn't happen and uh the question
is is well asked and really gets to the
heart of that
we have a great bonus show for you today
teenagers
are helping each other get covered shots
when their parents are anti-vaxx
fascinating that this is what's going on
the
defiant uh action of
teenagers is to get themselves
vaccinated even when their parents don't
want them to unbelievable
but trials to suck carbon dioxide from
the air are going to start across the
united kingdom
and the texas senate has approved a bill
limiting
how race and racism can be taught in
public school classrooms
all of those stories and more on today's
bonus show i would love it if you joined
us on the bonus show
pat will be joining me why don't you
join me as well
you can get instant access by signing up
at joinpacman.com
thanks a lot for watching today's show i
just want to take a second to tell you
about
today's sponsors blinkist is the app
that helps you become a more
well-rounded person
by letting you read or listen to an
entire nonfiction book in just 15
minutes
you can try it for free and get 25
percent off a subscription
by going to blinkist.com david pakman